le conseil scientifique répète aussi
qu'un nouveau confinement généralisée ne
serez à son sens ni possible ni
souhaitable car ils ne seraient pas
acceptées par la population et aurait
des conséquences économiques et
sociétales très lourde en cas de besoin
il envisagerait plutôt un confinement
partiel notamment conseillé aux
populations plus âgées et plus à risque
donc ma première question et précise sur
le premier ministre pourquoi n'avoir pas
choisi cette seconde option
j'ai une seconde question à vous poser
concernant les études scientifiques et
économiques sur lesquels vous font dès
maintenant semblait nous expliquait il
ya quelques instants va pourtant
répondons à notre rapporteur qu' il n'y
a pas que le conseil scientifique alors
sur quelle étude vous font de fonder
vous est ce que c'est le conseil de
défense ou à l'intérieur du conseil de
défense dont le fonctionnement
évidemment est complètement opaque pour
nous est-ce que c'est toujours le
conseil scientifique est ce que c'est le
haut conseil pour la santé publique est
ce que vous pouvez répondre clairement à
cette question et enfin j'en termine là
monsieur le monsieur le président j'ai
encore pas tout à fait compris qui
prenait réellement les décisions bon
j'ai pas compris
j'ai bien compris évidemment et c'est
normal coc l'exécutif mais c'est qui
dans l'exécutif est ce que c'est vous ou
est ce que c'est le président de la
république je vous donne un exemple
précis monsieur le premier ministre le
27 octobre
vous recevez les chefs de partis et de
groupes politiques dans le cadre d'une
concertation
on attendait des options il n'ya pas
d'option vous nous écoutez pour le
président de la république prend ses
décisions le lendemain est ce que le 27
octobre vous êtes au courant vous même
du contenu complet des décisions du
président de la république ou pas vous
17 s'est pas posé cette question là
c'est évidemment pas pour pour vous
gêner mais c'est simplement parce que
vous ouvrez les concertations avec
beaucoup d'organisations notamment les
forces politiques mais est ce que c'est
vous une fine et qui prenait les
décisions ou est ce que c'est le
président de la république
merci à vous tous merci beaucoup mais
c'est vrai qu'en absurdistan il est
parfois difficile de gouverner
eu égard à certaines entités
sécessionnistes je vous laisse la parole
monsieur le premier ministre
alors je commence par monsieur belge
il a employé une formule extrêmement
importante il a dit il faut assumer des
morts pour maintenir l'économie à faire
pour rappeler le dilemme je ne sais pas
si j'ai exactement noter vos termes il
me semble que c'est ça je voudrais bien
représentées devant votre commission mon
objectif c'est d'abord d'éviter les
morts et ensuite de maintien colo mais
c'est comme ça je le dis et je dis pas
mais je dis et alors les couacs la
technocratie aux folies l'absurde east
enfin tout ce que vous voulez normal en
démocratie j'entends tout tout tout et
tout le temps
enfin au jour d'aujourd'hui je constate
je constate que les mesures que nous
avons prises commence à avoir un impact
sanitaire
je reviens pas sur ce que je vous ai dit
fait prudent d'attendre il faut
transformer et cetera et quand par
ailleurs je regarde les chiffres
officiels de l'insee et de la banque de
france comme je vous invite à le faire
je constate que même dans le cadre de ce
deuxième confinement l'économie
française tient le choc beaucoup plus
qu'au premier beaucoup plus qu'au
premier bon donc ça veut dire que cet
équilibre que je recherche que nous
recherchons à ce jour il n'est pas
mauvais il n'est pas si loin d'être
atteint je dis ça parce que nous passons
notre temps à nous à nous auto flageller
à dire que tout va mal et c'est que la
situation est très difficile il ya des
gens qui meurent
ou un jour encore plusieurs centaines
dans le service de réanimation
la situation est grave et les mesures
difficiles mais cet équilibre que je
dois en permanence recherché dans le
moment présent
j'estime que j'ai des éléments pour dire
que on est sur la bonne voie il ya des
motifs d'espoir je leur dis quand même
devant cette commission parlais tout à
l'heure des vaccins ya des difficultés
et c'est bon mais il ya aussi des
éléments positifs qui montrent aussi que
notre pays tient le choc que notre pays
se bat que notre pays il ya quand même
une majorité déjà il ya beaucoup de gens
qui contestent port du masque qui font
qu'ils voient des complots partout et
c'est vous le savez tous ah bon en fait
je veux pas non plus que on oublie
celles et ceux nombreux qu'on entend
peut-être moins que les autres j'en
conviens mais qui applique qu'ils
comprennent certes qui se résignent mais
qui ne confondent pas la cible
la cible c'est la lutte contre
l'épidémie un cible c'est le virus à
chaque fois qu'on pense que c'est
quelqu'un d'autre lac cible en fait à
mon avis une erreur et un pas de côté
bon je reviens pas parce que le
président est il a bien dit c'est vrai
qu'il ya ce ce débat sur les libertés
est tout à fait la raison de dire
qu'effectivement quand on prend des
mesures de confinement aussi elles
portent atteinte
quelque part aux libertés publiques qui
ne me plaît absolument pas qui est
nécessaire mais qu'il me plaindre ne
demande pas non je reviens pas sur ce
que j'ai dit par rapport à un isolement
puisque je crois avoir longuement
répondu tant à monsieur abad cas
monsieur vallot simplement j'ajoute
qu'effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison l'aération des lieux clos est le
comment dire sans doute une nouvelle
enfin une nouvelle
l'observation scientifique montre
qu'effectivement plus on est dehors
c'est mieux que dedans et plus et aéré
mieux c'est bon on pourrait ajouter
aussi jeu puisque vous évoquez ça quand
même je le dis devant passer sur les
ailes et le souci de pédagogie que il
faut aussi appliquer les gestes barrière
voir le port du masque chez soi n'est
pas que c'est très difficile je j'ai
toujours été frappé comme parler des
lieux de contamination par une étude qui
a été faite par l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris sur ces personnels qui
était qui avait contracté la copie est
normal qu'un hôpital se disent mince
alors si j'aimais personnel qui contre
attaque au vide surtout s'ils ont
attrapé sur le trail c'est quand même
très embêtant
deuxièmement c'est des personnels dont
on peut penser que la sensibilisation à
la maladie est peut-être plus élevé que
dans la population en général et les
résultats de cette étude parce que
l'ap-hp avec beaucoup de personnel donc
pas mal de personnel qui avait eu la
qu'ovide étaient très claires sur leur
lieu de travail avait un respect absolu
des gestes barrières dans les transports
en commun lorsqu'il est pour celles des
centres qu'ils utilisaient port du
masque et c'est arrivé chez eux et comme
une 16 e représentation symbolique du
domicile on a l'impression que monsieur
virus n'y pénètre pas et là changement
complet des comportements et c'est
évidemment là a fortiori s'ils
recevaient chez eux des amis ou
plusieurs personnes que les
contaminations s'effectuer donc
effectivement dans les lieux clos
reprend et il ya toute une série
d'évolutions et dans les lieux clos
collectif c'est effectivement il faut
faudra revoir les scènes d'aération et
pas n'importe quel système d'aération
elle savait que des endroits dans les
avions ils sont très bien payés des
techniques d'air pulsé est venue de
considérations techniques dans
lesquelles je vous prierais de ne pas me
demander d'entrer mais vous avez raison
il faut dans les écoles avoir un plan à
long terme de la même peu
de cette crise sur les systèmes
d'aération
je pense que c'est un vrai une vraie
question qui est posée le bon je réponds
monsieur à votre à votre question bon
d'abord vous demandez vous avez beaucoup
insisté qui prend la décision
je voudrais pas que ça vous empêche de
dormir
le principal c est ce que la décision
qui est prise est bonne pas bonne on est
pas bon je pourrais vous faire une
réponse juridique
la plupart des décisions qui sont prises
ce sont des décrets signés par le
premier ministre c'est rare que ce soit
des décrets il peut y en avoir délibéré
en conseil des ministres entraînant la
situe la signature du pernambouc mais
dans les doigts que vous avez voté ns et
messieurs les députés
ces décrets du président est donc
juridiquement voilà si ça peut vous
rassurer je ne sais rien et c'est moins
bon mais voilà je ne veux pas faire un
grand court institutionnelles ou
constitutionnelles ici surtout pas il se
trouve que sous la vème république
le pana république a effectivement un
certain rôle à jouer une fille pas sûr
d'ailleurs que sa date de 2020 voyez
vous donc effectivement il ya un conseil
de défense nationale qui est une
instance a aussi en ciel que j'ai vu
fonctionner avant 2020 bien avant donc
où le présent de la république choisi de
réunir les ministres principalement
concerné est mort ce jeu là aussi dans
l'esprit des institutions nous sommes en
situation de crise
un conseil de défense au niveau
politique il y a de la même façon un
centre interministériel de crise
opérationnel avec plutôt des
fonctionnaires qui se réunit un conseil
de défense très de ces sujets je vois un
toutes ces questions moi je ne trouve
souvent pas chocas un fonctionnement
normal dès lors que dès lors que 1
ces décisions soit expliqué transparence
et cetera le cas et que lorsqu'elles
relèvent du parlement soit au titre de
ces compétences propres soit au titre de
son pouvoir de contrôle et bien aidé en
soit rendu compte devant lui
mais voilà enfin encore une fois la
question de forces est pas tellement
comment sont prises décision ça peut
être certes je ne sous estime pas votre
mais je voudrais pas me tuer mais c'est
surtout quelle est la nature de la
décision prise et est elle de nature à
répondre à situation de fait face à
laquelle nous nous prouvons jeu quand
même je précise à tous les députés pour
revient pas c'est que lorsque je rêve
toutes les décisions prises pour lutter
contre à kovy depuis a fait l'essentiel
des décisions je vous rappelle
l'essentiel très grands noms
ce sont les préfets repentant de l'état
qui les ont prises et de beaucoup et le
début vous le savez enfin début et dès
lors comme une gestion territories et
pas forcément toutes les mêmes partout
pas forcément tout et même temps enfin
vous avez une collection d'arrêtés
préfectoraux qui encombreraient sûrement
votre commission si vous en demander la
communication mais en est à votre votre
disposition questions sur les organismes
experte au sur lesquels s'appuie cette
défiance c'est une sujet extrêmement
intéressant donc il ya vous le savez le
législateur le législateur sur
proposition du gouvernement a créé au
tout début de la pandémie en fin de son
arrivée en france
un conseil scientifique qui rend des
avis qui rend des avis que convenir que
nous analysons que nous suivons le plus
possible mais qui forme partie des
éléments à la disposition de l'autorité
politique pour prendre sa décision
je voudrais dire devant votre commission
certes tu veux ce serait étonnant quand
même qu'on ne tiennent aucun compte des
avis du conseil scientifique va faire là
aussi j'entends c'est encore un des sels
de cette crise entre ce qui veut dire à
vous êtes prisonnier du conseil
scientifique pas d'autonomie de pouvoir
politique et puis c'est ici je crois
d'avoir entendu dans plusieurs questions
qui veut dire mais le conseil
scientifique vous avez dit que voulait
pas fait donc les les avis du conseil
scientifique constitue évidemment un des
éléments qui concourent à la prise des
décisions je vous le confirme sur
députés vous avez également raison d'eux
appelée que le conseil scientifique
n'est pas la seule autorité experte al
que consultent les pouvoirs publics et
qu'ils existent il en existe plusieurs
là aussi peut-être que semblait national
dira un jour qui en a trop il ya santé
publique phrase plutôt elle autour de
l'appareil statistique épidémiologique
il ya la haute autorité de santé
nous avons évoqué déjà les stratégies de
tests ou les stratégies vaccinales c'est
la loi qui c'est pas moi qui ai fixé la
compétence de cet été et puis je crois
pour abc tv ce député il ya le haut
conseil de santé publique qui est
effectivement un organe aussi
extrêmement important qui préexistait
pour le coup à cette crise et qui lui
pour faire simple et plutôt celui qui
valide les protocoles sanitaires les
protocoles sanitaires nationales j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de ceux applicables
aux écoles on peut parler de ceux
applicables au milieu professionnel dans
les transports et vous avez toute une
multitude d'avis du haut conseil de
santé publique
d'ailleurs plusieurs parfois sur le même
sujet on lui demande d' affiner lui
voilà il est j'allais dire une visée
opérationnelle n'est plus sur
l'opérationnalité des décisions que sur
la stratégie de conduite d'un gestion de
la crise
alors encore une fois il m'appartient
pas de dire si ça fait trop ou pas assez
ce député s'agit pas justement que mais
peut-être à froid c'est ce que c'est un
peu ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
sur les ars les préfets etc
il y aurait sûrement des choses à
meilleur a dit en effet moi moi je suis
au front c'est pas c'est banal eux c'est
pendant caméo feu quand elle écoute et
on va on va revoir on va remettre tout
ça par terre et le reconstruire
quitte à ce que ce soit mieux je ne
doute pas de la pureté des intentions de
ce que dit ça m'a fait c'est inopportun
attendons que tout ça soit fini et
tirons-en dès que les conséquences
structurelles le cas échéant si on
montre que cette organisation y compris
au niveau des experts n'est pas
pleinement satisfait en tout cas
l'expérience que j'ai comme comme
premier ministre
c'est que bon d'abord je pense qu'il
vaut mieux avoir plusieurs experts qu'un
seul vous dit quitte à ce qu'ils soient
spécialisés et voilà c'est c'est plus
éclairant pour les pour les pouvoirs
publics
rien ne m'autorise à dire devant cette
commission que la qualité scientifique
des productions expertime est
défaillante ou pas bonne voilà en même
temps voilà vous avez cité d'inde et des
premiers avis du conseil scientifique
encore une fois il faut pas s'appuyer
dessus
quand sa rage et db connaître quand ça
n'arrange pas quoi c'est un ce souci de
rigueur jeu puisque vous citez va le gg
j'ai je vous rappelle quand même que
dans son la vie du 26 octobre je dis ça
pour vous toutes et vous tous
puisqu'on en a cité le conseil
scientifique s'est déclaré lui même
surpris par l'explosion de l'épidémie
surpris par l'explosion
d'accord et pourtant comme vous l'avez
rappelé il avait prononcé un certain
nombre d'observations dès l'été dernier
il ya une question très importante à
quels jeux termine c'est les populations
âgée ou à risque
je crois que vous avez interrogé
là-dessus
effectivement ça ça c'est une question
qui est revenue dans le débat consiste à
dire oui mais écoutez timar le plus
alors à l'essentiel de cette maladie ce
sont les personnes très âgées présentant
pas sous le contrôle de d'éminents
médecins des polypathologies d'abord
qu'on regarde c'est vrai mais pas tout à
fait il ya quand même hélas hélas des
personnes jeunes qui meurent de cette
maladie je peux vous assurer je vous
disais tout à l'heure que je faisais le
tour des établissements de santé dans
les services de réanimation je vois même
si elles n'y sont pas majoritaires des
personnes qui
en moins de 60 ans mais effectivement
vient parfois l'idée que l'on pourrait
nous confie dès que les personnes les
plus âgées ou en tout cas vraiment les
plus vulnérables allemagne je vais vous
dire très honnêtement je pense que c'est
une très mauvaise idée
je vous le dis une très mauvaise idée
d'abord je fais observer avantage
nationale que pas un pays ne s'est
aventuré
bon alors là peut-être que si on le
faisait seul monsieur le député nous
entrerions en absurdie gens sérieux mais
au delà de considérations éthiques
c'est qu'elle ne revienne pas mais qui
sont quand même majeurs le ya quand même
un consensus scientifique pour dire que
ce serait d'abord inefficace parce que
vous ne pourriez jamais créé un cordon
sanitaire complètement étanche
autour de ces populations on vous retire
si vous laisser se développer le virus
tout autour en disant mais voilà
allons-y les plus jeunes de toute façon
il ne développe pas de forme grave et
encore moins des formes mortelles de la
maladie et protégeant les autres ça
marche pas et au bout d'un certain temps
les personnes vulnérables les personnes
âgées serait rattrapé par la patrouille
sauf à mettre des systèmes de contrôle
pour les isolés qui ne seraient qui
serait un faisable voire indignes de
l'état démocratique
dans lequel nous nous trouvons et puis
surtout je le répète ce serait me
semble-t-il méconnaître cette épidémie
qui pour les personnes les plus jeunes a
fait rouler moins vulnérables provoque
aussi des dégâts tout tout à fait
comment dire significatif donc ça c'est
quelque chose de décent ciel je crois à
dire ça n'est pas une piste valide
merci beaucoup monsieur dharréville
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
chacun peut mesurer le caractère inédit
de la situation est donc la difficulté
de l'exercice qui vous incombent
cette audition est singulière puisque
nous entendons le maître d'oeuvre du
déconfinement et le premier ministre
dur confinement or leur confinement
appel à s'interroger sur les ratés du du
déconfinement il faut effectivement se
demander ce que nous aurions pu mieux
faire regardez du côté des
responsabilités publiques par exemple on
s'interroge sur les mesures prises ou
pas prises pour soutenir l'hôpital et
notamment en prévision d'une
recrudescence épidémique ce n'est qu'un
exemple vous avez annoncé réfléchir sur
des mesures de plus long terme j'imagine
en tirant les leçons de ski de ce qui
s'est passé ne pensez vous pas qu'il
serait nécessaire de mettre les
hypothèses sur la table nous avait
plutôt deal inverse
mais moi je crois que nous devrions un
peu plus réfléchir à voix haute et je
voudrais savoir si de votre point de vue
la réduction démocratique dans laquelle
nous sommes contraints depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant n'est quand même pas un
problème
le choix qui a été fait de la voie du
management de la verticalité de
l'autorité d'une certaine façon n'a pas
permis à nos yeux de placer suffisamment
notre société les citoyennes et les
citoyens les différents acteurs sociaux
territoriaux en situation de lutte et
d'action face au virus cela n'est-il pas
venu alimenter d'ailleurs une crise de
confiance dans cette épreuve
individuelle et collective lourde les
différentes institutions et
organisations n'avait-elle pas besoin
d'être plus conforté associés mobilisés
face aux virus et aux à l'ensemble des
défis auxquels nous étions confrontés
deuxième question il ressort des
auditions l'idée d'un affaiblissement
progressif de l'état
j'aimerais avoir votre avis à vous qui
entre donc au coeur du dispositif
aujourd'hui
avons-nous suffisamment les outils a
contrario certains n'ont ils pas parfois
été contournée il n'y a t'il pas besoin
de reconstruire une puissance publique
qui soit appuyée sur une fiction
fonction publique plus étoffée plus
respectés voilà l'état de l'état
troisième question pensez vous que
l'action suffisante a été entreprise
pour permettre un droit au vaccin pour
toutes et pour tous en france en europe
et dans le monde est une question qui
est encore devant nous mais je crois que
nous interroge toutes et tous il y en a
un peu plus je voulais mais aussi
quatrième question sur le sujet social
questions sociales prégnante pour les
jeunes je crois que les mesures prises
ne suffisent pas et pour les salariés en
activité partielle qui sont à 84 %
seulement de leurs salaires depuis trop
longtemps pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux et j'ai été surpris par l' usage de
l'activité partielle par carrefour si
vous avez des choses à nous dire
là-dessus
tandis qu'on s'interroge sur la capacité
de nos petits commerces à survivre merci
beaucoup monsieur des moulins monsieur
premier ministre dans vos propos
liminaire vous avez souligné le nombreux
échanges avec le voisin européen
est ce que vous pourriez être un petit
peu précis sur la nature de ces échanges
je pense que c'est une europe
l'europe est elle un atout effectivement
on souhaite une europe solidaire
est-ce que vous avez des pays
privilégiés vous avez parlé de la
chancelière allemande sur ses échanges
avec l'union européenne voire d'autres
pays
est-ce que
la prise de décision a pu être influencé
à votre niveau et pourquoi pas l'idée
c'est d'aller chercher les bonnes
pratiques partout dans le monde
ma deuxième question monsieur le premier
ministre concernent le l'acceptabilité
vous l'avez dit aussi dans dans vos
propos liminaire autant le fil
conducteur c'est effectivement la santé
avant tout on sent que dans cette crise
inédite très compliqué le critère de
l'acceptabilité prend une dimension de
plus en plus importante et je dirais
même que on pourrait craindre que ça se
croisent dans le sens où on pourrait
mettre l'acceptabilité un niveau
supérieur de celui de la santé je
voudrais simplement avoir votre retour
votre réflexion là dessus puisque cette
crise vous l'avait dit et vous le
répéter je pense que vous avez tout à
fait raison on va vivre avec ce virus
je ne sais pas si on va connaître une
troisième vague en tout cas il va
falloir qu'on accepte de vivre etc ce
virus est le degré d'acceptabilité me
paraît un critère primordial a laissé le
premier je vous en prie très bien je
réponds à la première question je
commence si vous permettez ces
volontaires sains de base sur
l'affaiblissement progressif de l'état
bon il est clair que l'état était mis à
rude épreuve
c'est sa responsabilité je les dis dans
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics
il est responsable la santé et les
responsables de la crise c'est pas le
cas dans tous les pays mais c'est comme
ça et encore une fois c'est après coup
qu'on ne change les règles du jeu c'est
pas pendant la partie s'il faut les
changer s'il faut les changer
moi il me semble vu de ma fenêtre que
l'état a tenu et a tenu l'état a été
soumis à rude épreuve et l'état a tenu
et je voudrais quand même puisque me
pose la question à monsieur député
rendre hommage à tous les tous les to
les fonctions parce que je les ai vus
dans le décompte n'a je les vois
aujourd'hui et ils sont d'ailleurs on a
des recommandations on peut encore
sûrement s'améliorer vous savez en en
préparant des relèves en formant
davantage à la crise on a on a des
questions comme ça qui sont tout à fait
pertinente mais
mon sentiment global c'est que certes au
prix de au prix de beaucoup d'efforts
auprès beaucoup d'eux auprès de beaucoup
de fatigue
les fonctionnaires ont joué un rôle
essentiel au plan central comme au plan
territorial et voilà sûrement qu'il ya
des choses à améliorer des choses à
renforcer et cetera mais je n'ai pas vu
comment dire j'ai vu un état comme un
pays comme tous les autres pays en
difficulté face à de cette crise à
laquelle est effectivement il ne
s'attendait pas mais je n'ai vu tenir
je le vois tenir c'est très dur mais je
le vois tenir et jeu je vais vous dire
je le dédie comprend semblait jeu je
crois en l'état
certains états qui est de plus en plus
des concentrés un état qui concerte un
état qui est avec les collectivités
territoriales
mais je pense qu'on le voit bien on a
besoin d'états dont sept dans une crise
comme celle là bonds est en tout cas
j'essaie de m'employer à lui donner les
moyens pour fonctionner autres alors du
coup vous avez par les gens j'ai noté un
e de réduction démocratique de crise de
confiance bon de crise de confiance dans
les pouvoirs publics je ne suis pas
certain pardonnez moi quel est vraiment
démarré avec la crise sanitaire parce
que nous en conviendrons tout c'est
quelque part il n'est pas donc plus
complètement étonnant vous le voyez
aussi dans d'autres pays un qui accepte
mal les mesures de freinage comme on dit
que l'acceptabilité ça revient aussi à
la deuxième est le deuxième question là
la patience de des opinions publiques
soient effectivement mises à rude
épreuve c'est aussi j'en profite pour le
dire parce que je me suis déjà exprimé
sur ce sujet le comment dire la
caractéristique propre de cette crise
j'ai dit que c'était un rendez vous avec
nous mêmes j'ai souvent employé cette
formule c'est à dire que l'état la
première responsabilité
je le répète mais on voit bien que on le
litre a efficacement contre elle que si
chacun de nous chaque concitoyen se fait
acteurs de la lutte contre la crise
c'est comme ça c'est c'est aussi une
leçon de responsabilité individuelle et
collective
c'est aussi pardonnez moi de dire
monsieur le député une une affaire de
solidarité et je je peux considérer que
je vais pas développer une forme grave
de la maladie
peut-être peut-être pas que je pense
qu'on se trompe on pense à ça on a fait
chacun pense ce qu'il veut ce député en
revanche c'est sûr que je peux la
transmettre à une personne qui elle est
vulnérable et donc ça suppose ma part un
acte de solidarité de conscience
collective pour adapter mes
comportements à cette réalité
c'est vraiment un défi collectif bien
sûr l'état est le premier responsable
responsable de tout bon c'est bien connu
c'est pas si simple
il a la première responsabilité il doit
faire face et le premier ministre
encore plus que les autres mais chacun
sent bien au fond de lui-même avec
j'allais presque dire bon sens que cette
une mobilisation collective
c'est une mobilisation quick et il
faudra vraiment en prendre conscience
c'est comme ça on peut pas ne pas ne pas
se soucier de ce qui se passe dans les
hôpitaux dans les services de
réanimation
il faut qu'ils soient tous très
attentifs et ça suppose que nous
adoptions adapter le comportement je
vraiment je ne suis pas dans l'idée sur
le député d'être dans une réduction
démocratique
franchement je pense que le parlement
encore sûrement des choses à améliorer
mais le parlement légifère le parlement
contrôle j'ai là pour ça c'est raté on
va pas refaire encore une fois la
dévolution des pouvoirs à la faveur de
cette crise mais il me semble que vous
jouer pleinement votre rôle quitte à ce
que ce soit parfois peu agréable pour le
voir exécutif et je vous dis je suis
offrant évidemment ça me prend beaucoup
de temps mais je
j'écoute je regarde tout ce que les uns
et les autres disent ainsi que nos
concitoyens soyez-en absolument assurer
sauf qu'au bout du bout si vous voulez
l'ennui c'est que sur 100 propos que je
reçois s'il me disait tous la même chose
et que je faisais le contraire je me
dirais il ya quelque chose qui va pas
bien sauf que je parle je parlais tout à
l'heure des scientifiques mais même tout
ce que j'entends partout ça n'est jamais
convergent et c'est normal mais c'est
normal et donc je suis là dans le cadre
des institutions de la république pour
assumer mes responsabilités
voilà et j'essaie de le faire après vous
même ou l'histoire d'hier et si c'est
bien fait ou mal fait ça sera sûrement
pas très bien fait ça sera peut-être pas
complètement mal fait c'est pour ça que
les comparaisons je viens votre question
sont toujours intéressantes
toujours extrêmement précieuse en un
tout nouveau inédit qui frappe les
autres donc quand même nous serions un
peu stupide de ne pas regarder ce qui se
passe ailleurs les outils qu'ils
utilisent les relation qu'ils ont avec
les collectivités décentralisées même
et encore une fois elle sait inscrivent
les dames d'une organisation et 6 juin
donc en a j'en profite pour le dirigeant
n'a pas parlé
un centre interministériel de crise en
fait je l'évoqué thaler et nous faisons
ce député benchmark flambard engrenage
je crois qu'il faut dire merci
un bar engrenage permanent permanent
d'accord au delà des contacts directs la
nature de ce que vous avez évoquées et
tous les jours tous les jours je regarde
pas que moi bien sûr bien fait qu'est ce
qui se passe dans les pays qui nous
entourent
quelle mesure ils prennent que leur
situation évidemment épidémique
c'est c'est vraiment indispensable
et puis je crois que c'était aussi à
votre question il ya l'europe bon
l'europe de la santé là évidemment on
est encore dans des politiques d'état
même si je vous rappelle
la france a proposé avec l'allemagne cet
été 20 août on a pris une initiative
pour essayer de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une approche commune au moins pour à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne régler
les questions de libre-circulation vous
avez tous mesdames et messieurs les
députés en mémoire tel pays qui dit mais
ressortissants je ne veux pas qu'ils se
rendent dans tel autre pays ou dans tel
autre région des pays parce que elle est
classée rouge en fin des classes et
comme présentant des risques plus grave
de circulation virale
bon donc nous essayons de comment dire
d'harmoniser les positions européennes
ça n'est pas simple mais il ya des
progrès parce qu'encore une fois les
stratégies sanitaires sont conduites
plus tôt par les états mais je pense
aussi que tu es des enseignements delà
de la crise il faudra que l'europe
prenne un peu plus de place dans
l'harmonisation des politiques
sanitaires
elle l'a fait ce j'en viens au droit au
vaccin puisque vous l'avez évoqué sa
nasa n'a échappé à personne en a
on a passé un accord un groupement de
commandes européen avec une task force
là je pense que ça ça va démontrer son
utilité puisque grâce à cette taxe force
européenne
nous avons déjà signé quatre accords qui
nous permettent dans le cadre de cette
commande globale d'acheter 100 millions
de doses permettant de vacciner 65
millions de personnes donc essayons on
réalise tous savent que vous me posez
c'est est-ce que ce qui aura droit au
vaccin pour tous je pense que ce député
que c'est la formule qui qui est que
vous avez utilisé est donc effectivement
c'est bien notre notre intention que
d'arriver à ce que la stratégie
vaccinale qu'il faut quand même
forcément prioriser comme dans toute
politique vaccinale
il y aura des publics prioritaires parce
que c'est comme ça et notamment
alors là pour le coup les personnes qui
de députés qui m'interrogeait tout à
l'heure les personnes qui sont les plus
vulnérables
évidemment à la maladie ou les
professionnels de santé seront à coup
sûr dans les priorités vaccinale mais
l'objectif effectivement c'est d'avoir
une approche la plus large possible
merci beaucoup monsieur sow forget c'est
le premier ministre vous n'étiez pas là
à cette époque là c'était edouard
philippe qui était premier ministre
mais quand il scandaleux du land cette
guerre a éclaté
finalement le ms a pris des mauvaises
décisions puisqu'elle a décidé d'arrêter
les études basées sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine il avait un autre scandale
en même temps puisque les mêmes auteurs
ont publiés dans le new england journal
of medicine en faveur du rem désir qui
depuis on l'apprend seraient toxiques
combien même l'europe a acheté des
millions de doses et le problème c'est
que c'est un péché originel parce que
aucun mea culpa n'a été fait parce qu'à
l'époque
miss véran s'est empressée de
communiquer sur la dangerosité du
produit
et puis finalement personne n'est jamais
revenue en arrière personne ne s'est
jamais excusé alors que il alla des
faussaires il ya des gens qui ont écrit
cette étude qui sont des faussaires qui
sont base qu'il y avait une fausse
société des faux employés des fausses
données d'hôpitaux avec des patients
français qui revendiquait avoir des
données ethniques qui sont interdites en
france on n'a jamais eu de feedback là
dessus on n'a jamais eu de quelqu'un du
gouvernement qui nous disent on s'est
trop on s'est trompé en suivant ce
papier ces gens là seront poursuivies
ont les attaquera nous mêmes et je
trouve dommage parce que la suspicion
contre le monde médical et scientifique
contre big pharma elle est née à ce
moment là et la suspicion que vous aurez
deux mains sur le vaccin
elle est née de ce péché originel où
finalement on n'a pas entendu d'excusés
de mesures correctrices je voudrais
aussi revenir sur ce que vous avez dit
dans le fait que vous êtes un peu la
peau de la sécurité sanitaire
finalement moi justement ce que
j'aimerais votre part qu'au premier
s'est pas noyé dans le too sanitaire
dans le too sanitaires ce que je
voudrais c'est que vous et qu'il y
briller parce qu'on ne doit pas être
dans finalement une dynamique de une
république des médecins et c'est un
médecin qui vous le dis parce que là
quand vous nous dites aujourd'hui faut
porter le masque à la maison vous vous
rendez compte quand même que chez les
gamins on se construit le cerveau jeu là
je parle comme scientifique mais le
cerveau le social de l'être humain il se
construit en reconnaissant des visages
une expertise unique unique qui fait de
nous capables de reconnaître des
milliers et des milliers de visages ont
construit le lien social
on construit son schéma corporel ont
construit peut-être ces voies de la
lecture d'apprentissage à lecture
si demain dans dix ans dont quinze en a
qu'on s'aperçoit qu'on a des enfants
dyslexiques dyscalculiques dyspraxiques
que peut-être ils ont une amputation
partielle de leur champ de vision
regardez vous avez une amputation du
championnat faire il ya des risques de
chutes chez les personnes âgées
il ya beaucoup de choses qui aujourd'hui
ont peut-être les sous-estimer elle peut
seront peut-être irrattrapable dont
quelques années dans quelques dizaines
d'années donc j'aimerais vous soyez
prudents quand en disant aux gens porter
des masques en permanence parce que ce
n'est pas anodin pour le développement
de l'être humain
c'est vraiment tout sauf anodin personne
n'en parle on s'entend bien on en parle
et enfin vous avez parlé du benchmark
l'étalonnage du parangon âge de découpe
à raison vous avez pu faire je suis
d'accord que finalement évidemment vrai
pas responsable de tout parce qu'il ce
virus là il s il serait bien prétentieux
le ce virus là il
il a ses préférences géographiques de
temps dont il je souhaiterais vous dire
quand même que moi je levais le choix je
le fais mais je le vis en suisse en
suisse de confinement il est moins
douloureux il est moins important il ya
observe du coc vide le jeu longtemps
mais le sabé sa baisse comme ailleurs
aujourd'hui et je n'ai pas le sentiment
de vivre aussi apprécié que quand je
suis à paris je ne mangeais pas obligé
de sortir une attestation
je vis au niveau socialement mieux cette
deuxième crise est comme il est je vous
invite à merci à ne pas être l'apôtre
juste de la sécurité mais de peut-être
merci parce qu'on changerait les choses
merci beaucoup nous rassurer avec l'air
du lac léman
monsieur aubert monsieur boyer ministre
alors il ya un proverbe qui dit vérité
en deçà des pyrénées erreur au-delà
c'est le même virus des deux côtés et
pourtant la série les commerces l'année
essentielle sont ouverts jusqu'à 18
heures et en catalogne
eh bien c'est la limite de 800 mètres
carrés qui fait qu'on peut ouvrir un
commerce
on favorise plutôt des commerces petit
sur la base de quelles études d'impact
sanitaire
avez vous estimez que la concentration
des flux dans les grandes surfaces
étaient moins risqués les moins
dangereux que la distribution des flux
dans les petits commerces
allez savoir ce qu'on adopte souvent
cette logique des fluides ont joué
savoir qui a pondu cette étude
et en quoi diffère des airs de ce que
pourraient avoir les espagnols
deuxièmement vous avez parlé de la prise
de décision politique
ce que vous pourriez nous éclairer dont
vous nous avez expliqué la répartition
des tâches entre le président de
république république où les instances
qui lui sont reliés et le prévenu savait
gouvernement et comme vous le savez le
président de la république n'est pas
pénalement responsable de ses actions
la différence du gouvernement donc le
choix quelque part de reposer sur des
organismes haddock qui sont centrés
autour du président de la république
engage ou peut engager une forme
d'hybridation au plan juridique
et une forme d' ambiguïté sur la
responsabilité des acteurs est ce que la
raison pour laquelle certains organes
ont été développées autour du président
de la république en réalité est lié à ce
problème juridique de responsabilité
pénale
enfin sur la question des vaccins vous
avez dit nous avons une bonne nouvelle
avec donc ces négociations au niveau de
l'union européenne
aujourd'hui c'était le 17 novembre le
l'un des laboratoires américains a
indiqué que les négociations étaient
prolongées mais qui avait pas d'accord
ferme et que les européens se devait se
dépêcher au risque sinon de se faire
doubler par d'autres pays qui pourraient
acheter des vaccins à notre place renaud
muselier présidente de l'association des
régions de france
interpellé aux libéraux aujourd'hui
est-ce que la france devrait pas prendre
une initiative dans ce domaine pour
acheter sécuriser ces vaccins et est ce
qu'il serait possible peut-être d'avoir
un jour un vaccin français merci
beaucoup
j'ai entendu parler des pyrénées donc
inéluctablement je passe la parole à
monsieur habib parce que je sens très
évidemment que les problèmes n'a pas de
sens de vous en parler
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez dit à juste
les gens tout à l'heure que vous appelez
au sens des responsabilités
on est enfin des travaux de la
commission denquête je voudrais rappeler
qu' il n'ya pas l'apanage du seul groupe
socialiste mais à chaque fois qu'il a
été demandé à l'assemblée nationale
l'autorisation de confiner nous l'avons
voté est donc cet esprit de
responsabilité qui nous a habité qui
nous a amené à dire que à situation
exceptionnelle il fallait des réponses
exceptionnelles
elle nous autorise aujourd'hui à vous
dire qu'il ya des choses qui ont comme
on dirait en béarn et dans le geste
qu'ils n'ont pas qu'ils ont clocher vous
allez parler d'acceptabilité vous avez
dit que cette acceptabilité 7 /
supportabilité diminue avec le temps
bien sûr mais elle diminue d'autant plus
qu'il n'ya pas de confiance qu'il n'y a
pas de cohérence qu'il n'y a pas de
compréhension de nos concitoyens je vous
en donner quelques exemples
pourquoi avoir mis autant de temps a
insisté sur le télétravail et ça c'est
la deuxième vague est ce que le medef
c'est souvent ce que l'on entend
a eu un rôle négatif en évitant cette ce
recours au télétravail
je souhaiterais vous entendre là dessus
sur les universités j'ai deux fils qui
sont les étudiants mes fils dès le début
dès la rentrée universitaire m'ont dit
c'est pas possible
les amphithéâtres sont bondés nous avons
les uns et les autres évoqué cela dans
l'hémicycle pointé la difficulté pour
les étudiants de de fréquenter pourquoi
avoir mis autant de temps à adopter des
dispositifs pour créer de la
distanciation ou pour diviser le nombre
d'étudiants réunis sur les déplacements
un département que vous connaissez bien
que je sais que vous aimez que c'est à
dire le mien on a été complètement
épargnés par la première vague 93e
département et puis on a eu une flambée
mais pourquoi ne pas avoir mis
d'interdiction de déplacement pour les
huit métropoles
vous seriez venu avec moi monsieur le
premier ministre dans l'avion entre pau
et paris où entre biarritz et paris vous
auriez vu le nombre de gens qui se
déplaçait au moment de la toussaint et
on le savait ça et on avait la
possibilité d'anticiper
voilà j'ai fini sur sa simplement
monsieur je vais conclure monsieur le
président sur la culture du risque
vous avez raison mais il ya un vrai
problème en france on sait très bien
qu'on a un déficit de la dessus et
disons les choses telles qu'elles sont
si ça marche et c'est parce que les
préfets eux avec cette culture du risque
ils ont cette culture et ils l'ont ils
nous ont permis de fonctionner jeudi le
dis très clairement ce n'est pas vrai
d'autres administrations et je pense
notamment de la rs et donc disons les
choses très clairement le code de santé
publique prévoit qu'en situation
exceptionnelle le préfet peut prendre la
mesure
pourquoi n'at-on pas favoriser une prise
de responsabilité sur les ars par les
préfets à ce moment particulier de la
crise merci monsieur habib mais je ne
voulais pas vous censurez bien au
contraire parce que je sentais que dans
cette discussion béarnaise la sauce se
prenait madame vos nerfs
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre à merci
vous avez déjà été très complet sur
beaucoup de questions
j'aimerais revenir avec vous à
l'introduction sur ce que les français
nous disent dans nos circonscriptions
qu'ils sont un peu là c'est peut-être
d'une forme de sémantique qui est
utilisée autour de la culpabilisation je
vous cite en date du 11 septembre
demain dépend de vous est ce que ça veut
dire que j'allais dire l'état l'état
d'une certaine façon se désengage quand
vous dites demain dépend de vous donc en
fait tous reposerait sur les épaules des
français et puis il ya une vidéo qui a
été vu de nombreuses fois de réanimation
c'est à dire commence par un
anniversaire et ça se termine en
réanimation
c'est vraiment très lourd à voir et
c'est vrai que les français en ont un
petit peu assez d'être d'être à ce point
culpabiliser également de la même façon
vous avez dit là le 11 novembre
ce n'est pas le moment de desserré la
bride aux français hélas cette phrase
peut-être sorti d'un contexte un je les
lui dans les médias a profondément
choqué les français parce que les
français ne doivent pas être tenus en
bride mais doivent être respectées il me
semble et je suis sûr que vous êtes
complètement d'accord avec moi alors
j'aimerais qu'on se situe en mars ce
n'était pas vous le premier ministre
vous ne dirigez pas le gouvernement à ce
moment là et je pense que on avait le
droit de se tromper mais depuis on sait
qu'il y à 166 étude publiée dans le
monde qui démontre qu'il y à un
traitement précoce efficace et qu'on
peut faire tout à fait différemment dans
la prise en charge des personnes à
partir du moment où elles sont testées
positives
il y a également sur le bureau du
ministre de la santé mais aussi sur le
bureau de monsieur jérôme salomon des
études préventive basée sur l'analyse
the use et qui permettent d'être
complètement prédictive et qui
permettrait ce que vous aviez souhaité
déjà plusieurs reprises de faire un
confinement territorialisée puisque en
effet le virus est beaucoup plus présent
dans les selles 1500 fois plus et donc
c'est beaucoup plus facile de prédire
dans une métropole
1 une explosion on va dire de l'épidémie
or cela n'est toujours pas utilisé alors
que c'est prouvé depuis le mois de
juillet donc en fait tout cela
permettrait en effet d'arriver à faire
ce que j'appelle peut-être une
évaluation qui nous manquent jusqu'à
présent à la fois sanitaire mais vous
nous avez redit à quel point et je vous
en remercie de vouloir protéger la santé
des français mais une évaluation
économique sociale parce que aujourd'hui
il y à une explosion des suicides vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que je suis
psychiatre je suis extrêmement inquiète
de la répercussions sociales et
j'aimerais encore dire deux choses
concernant sur les tel qu à madame
bonheur et couvre les tests et l'impact
financier de ces tests puisqu'on est à
plus de 2,2 milliards
ça a été estimé à fin 2020 or avec cette
somme nous pourrions très largement
construire plusieurs établissements mais
riche de sens elle est terminée pardon
encore les 26 que vous
l'évaluation bénéfice/risque il me
semble qu'il n'a pas été suffisamment
fait mesure les de la kz1 puisque c'est
la première fois que nous allons
utiliser un vaccin est qu'il n'y a aucun
monsieur le premier ministre je vous
laisse répondre merci chère madame
d'abord je voulais dire j'ai pas dit de
qu'il fallait serrer la bride des
français je parlais des mesures que nous
avons prises et dont je continue à
penser qu'il n'est pas encore que le
moment n'est pas encore venu de les
assouplir donc ne me faites pas dire ce
que je n'ai pas dit je ne pense pas vous
avoir démontré que l'état en quoi que ce
soit se désengageaient et pour autant je
confirme que ce que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs que la faire sans que
la lutte pardon contre l'épidémie et la
sphère de toutes et de tous j'ai appelé
à l'esprit de responsabilité
ça n'a rien à voir avec la
culpabilisation
culpabilisation l'état ne se désengage
pas les l'état doit susciter
l'engagement de chaque citoyen
cette nécessité en règle générale
d'ailleurs c'est ma conception de la vie
publique et en particulier dans le cas
qui nous qui nous occupe dans les
moments extrêmement difficiles que que
nous vivons vous avez parlé d'un
traitement précoce jeu
c'est pas de quoi vous parlez madame
tout cas je n'en connais pas et de la
même façon je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire qu' il faudrait renoncer au test
pour construire des établissements de
santé
quand on a une épidémie comme celle-là
il est indispensable que le moins de
gens la contractent et que le moins de
gens possible finissent à l'hôpital
sinon 20 j'en sais rien à ce moment-là
abrogeant la ceinture de sécurité n'est
ce pas allons-y conduisons n'importe
comment et retrouvons nous tous dans les
services d'urgence et de réanimation
c'est un raisonnement bardon madame mais
dans lequel je ne peux pas je ne peux
pas me reconnaître le dans tout ce que
vous avez dit en revanche si vous
permettez il ya un point dans lequel je
me reconnais tout à fait qu'ils sont les
incidences psychologiques de la crise
sanitaire du confinement mais de
l'ensemble des dimensions c'est un vrai
sujet incombe mesure qu'on voit ce qui
me donne l'occasion de vous dire puisque
nous n'avons pas évoqué ce terme depuis
le début de cette audition je suis
particulièrement fier même si c'est mon
processeur qu'il avait négocié en large
part d'avoir signé le ségur de la santé
peu de jours après mon arrivée je
voudrais vous dire madame que la plus
value si je puis m'exprimer ainsi que
j'ai apporté c'est de demander à ce que
au delà des indispensables
revalorisation indiciaire et
indemnitaire pour améliorer
l'attractivité de nos établissements de
santé il y aussi des crédits pour des
créations d'emplois dans le système de
soin et en particulier j'avais notamment
évoqué la santé mentale qui devraient en
bénéficier parce que de mon point de vue
elle se trouve effectivement en
difficulté
structurellement et particulièrement
pour faire face aux conséquences de
la crise sanitaire bon je vais à
l'envers des questions vous m'excuserez
donc à monsieur le député du beau
département de des pyrénées atlantiques
je je je reconnais bien volontiers qu'il
a fait preuve de responsabilité en
votant les textes les orientations que
je lui ai soumise
il me dit il n'y a pas de n'ya pas
toujours de cohérence il dira d'abord
sur les universités
c'est un sujet je rappelle simplement je
constate avec lui nous avions fait des
protocoles sanitaires avec des questions
de distanciation et sociale dans les
amphithéâtres
sachez le et effectivement j'ai pu
constater tout à fait qu'en certains
endroits c'est un fait tout seul devant
les arènes ils n'ont pas été respectées
ou appliquée avec toute la rigueur
nécessaire
c'est tout à fait exact nous avons
ensuite corrigé le tir avec la
conférence nationale des universités et
l'ensemble du dispositif d'enseignement
supérieur avec la ministre madame vidal
vous avez évoqué le sujet extrêmement
important et télétravail là dessus ça
mérite qu'on s'y appesantir alors il ya
deux questions me sentais la question
consistait à dire est ce que on n'aurait
pas dû maintenir le télétravail juste
pas enfin je l'interprète comme ça en
sortie du premier confinement et a
fortiori aujourd'hui donc
c'est vrai qu'il s'est beaucoup qu'il a
beaucoup diminué
mais c'est un sujet me bouge parce que
là dessus un homme comme vous ne peut
que m'a prouvé qu'il relève quand même
d'abord du dialogue social et des
partenaires sociaux
vous avez d'abord vous avez d'ailleurs
m'a d'ailleurs interrogé sur la position
du medef
non et c'est toujours la voie que nous
avons privilégié et que nous
continuerons à privilégier
il y a eu vous le savez des dispositions
qui ont été prises que nous avons
introduites dans le protocole sanitaire
applicables aux entreprises ces faits là
depuis depuis quelques semaines et qui à
force obligatoire mais effectivement
pour progresser encore sur tes travail
c'est la sphère des partenaires sociaux
y sont en train d'en discuter sont en
train de discuter vous me permettez je
peux pas vous dire et encore moins
commenter la position de telle ou telle
organisation c'est pas le rôle du
premier ministre
il passe bien ils pensent mal non parce
que je souhaite c'est que par le
dialogue social j'ai toujours été
favorable au dialogue social
toujours ce sujet progresse vous voyez
bien mesdames et messieurs les députés
connaît sur un sujet culturel parce
qu'en réalité dans les réticences
étaient très dans le fait que il se soit
si rapidement arrêté à partir du 11 mai
bien que ben finalement je vous le dis
je vous dis comme je le sens comme je
les ressentis comme je lai entendu ni
les entrepreneurs ni les salariés
n'était véritablement favorable au
télétravail pour des raisons diverses
je parle pas le télétravail comme lutte
de la crise sanitaire on y revenus le
vol du télétravail en général bon et moi
mon voeu voyez vous c'est que le
télétravail survivent à la crise
sanitaire bien il faut mais ça c'est un
instinct pour ça que dire que ceci est
indispensable c'est pas une évolution
culturelle c'est une évolution des
mentalités faut revoir l'organisation du
travail derrière
c'est pas simplement que les salariés
soient dotés des outils informatiques
c'est le b à ba leur permettant d'être
haye et d'ailleurs
l'administration elle-même et confrontez
vous le savez à cette question et à ce
problème
on a fait des progrès en plusieurs
manches enfin on peut pas tout régler
d'un coup mais au-delà de ça je pense
que là nous avons une évolution beaucoup
plus forte qui pourrait être oserais-je
de dire une héritage positif de cette
période de cette crise si grave
consistant à dire évidemment on peut pas
télétravail est tout le temps en temps
normal rien ne remplace les relations
humaines les contacts humains c'est
pourquoi les salariés sont aussi
extrêmement désireux d'avoir le plus
possible en travaillant très ancienne
mais derrière ça voilà il ya aussi le
nouveau rapport à la ville peut-être une
répartition de la population plus plus
homogène un recours aux déplacements et
aux mobilités différents là on a en a
soulevé la s'il peut dire un chantier
qui n'est pas nouveau qui doit
progresser tout cas dans l'immédiat
la position du gouvernement est claire
télétravail est partout où cela est
possible et je vous dis que la milice le
travaillement bord ne ménage pas son
énergie pour ça il faut à tout prix que
ce soit appuyé sur du dialogue social
c'est ce que nous faisons et 10 ans ils
y sont et troisièmement nous devons
inscrire ce qui apparaît comme une une
réponse subie à une situation d'urgence
sanitaire vers quelque chose de beaucoup
plus structurelle qui suppose que notre
regard collectif sur télétravail temps
des employeurs que des salariés aient
voulu c'est un des enjeux auxquels je
suis acheté le tout à fait mobiliser et
monsieur le député vous êtes revenu sur
préfet ars c'était à la fin de votre
question semble avoir déjà répondu
encore une fois voyez jeu il se trouve
que dans ma vie pour elle j'ai beaucoup
travaillé au 1500 t il se trouve que
j'ai été secrétaire général de
préfecture sous préfet donc voilà match
nul balle au centre
je ne voudrais pas qu'on exagère quand
même
du vécu que janelle le hiatus entre les
deux d'accord
vraiment je vous dis mon vécu en
observation je dis pas que tel ou tel
endroit il peut eu des problèmes mais je
pense qu'il faut surtout pas les
exagérer en tout cas je vous répond en
toute franchise comme pour le reste
devant votre commission
et puis je vous le redis si en terme
d'organisation de l'état et du rôle
respectif de ces instances il y a lieu
le moment venu dans le sens la question
que vous avez posé de tirer des
conséquences sans doute faudra-t-il le
faire j'invite simplement au plan
national je vais déjà dit c'est pas tout
à fait le moment de faire la tournée
toon osaer est où le préfet quels qu'ils
soient ils sont vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs sur le pont il se démène il
travaille je les vois tous évidemment
avec leurs difficultés ils se débattent
mais n'exagérons pas le problème est
surtout s'il existe règle règle on le
met pas un papa sur le pas au feu de
l'action
bon s'agissait pour propos monsieur
aubert il m'a parlé des des études mais
je pardonne moi la façon dont la
question est posée c'est pas tellement
grandes surfaces et petits commerces aux
débats d'accord c'est commerces de
première nécessité petit ou grand que je
sache ils sont tous ouverts petit voix
ils sont tous ouverts les autres
pourquoi on les a fermés j'ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises c'est effectivement
pas là petit ou gras qui avait le plus
de clusters je répète parce qu'il faut
toujours répéter
l'objectif c'est on est dans un grand
finement qui est le moins d'occasions de
sortir possible donc on le dit je répète
pour aller travailler
on le dit pour aller se nourrir on le
dit pour aller se former pour faire
simple déjà ça fait trois exceptions
forte au confinement donc les libertés
publiques gérées ce député ne sont pas
quand même si entre avait que ça
oui en fait pas tout à fait ce qu'on
veut mais faisait il se trouve qu'à
virus et à monsieur invisible qui nous
fait des tracas on peut penser que c'est
le gouvernement qui fait des tracas aux
gens il peut y avoir des motivations de
faire circuler cette cette façon de voir
les choses celui qui circulait qui nous
cause des tracas c'est le virus bon donc
on cherche encore une fois à limiter le
maximum possible les flux et
d'interaction et encore une fois nous
d'avoir essayé encore une fois je le dis
on a fait quand même un progrès en
disant on traite pareil les grandes
surfaces et petits commerces et en veut
je rappelle quand même qu'au premier
confinement l'intégralité des rayons des
grandes surfaces étaient ouverts bon je
le alors quand au benchmark vous avez
raison il ya un peu de tout c'est vrai
vous avez dit il ya des pays où les
commerces autres que ceux de proximité
j'insiste bien de première nécessité
pardon sont ouverts oui je pourrais
aussi vous citer des pays où ils sont
fermés
bon voilà encore une fois vous avez des
pays
je pense à l'autriche où ils ont laissé
certaines activités économiques ouverte
moyennant quoi ils ont fermé des écoles
récemment ce n'est pas le choix que nous
avons fait et je l'assumé et je l'assumé
encore une fois ci en rap en respecte
tout ça nous devrions avoir des
perspectives favorables à la fin de ce
mois ou au début du mois de deux dessins
oui alors sur les vaccins ont
effectivement des un soutien de l'europe
pour passer les commandes nécessaires
bon après il ya la question effectuant
pourquoi le vaccin français enfin
développé par sanofi je suppose que
c'était ça la question n'est pas au même
point que les autres bon ça si tu me
fais pardonnez-moi à fait moi c'est pas
moi qui suis sur la paille à ça c'est
une question que je vous invite à poser
à l'entreprise concernée
en tout cas et je veux on se tient au
courant
il progresse et j'espère qu'il
progressera aussi voilà et je veux dire
que l'état est responsable de tout mais
c'est quand même pas lui qui fabrique
directement les vaccins ou qui les
produits ou qui fait les recherches
correspondante bon et ensuite là je
reviens à la toute première question
cette étude du land 7 oui c'est bon jeu
il se trouve que moi je les je n'ai pas
du tout suivi parce qu'elles étaient
faits j'étais pas premier ministre kan
ce texte est sorti et donc je me
souviens à l'époque ddd polémique
qu'elle a qu'elle a créée mais je veux
comment dire je
je n'ai pas de réponse à faire parce que
j'ai pas de d'éléments concrets à vous
donner monsieur sur ce sujet en tout cas
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
sur le port du masque vous l'avez évoqué
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas dit porter le
masque en permanence et d'une porte le
masque le plus possible voilà il faut le
plus possible oui c'est ce que je
comprends quand même de toute la
littérature scientifique et des mesures
de protection
après chacun agit avec avec sa
conscience mais je pense que c'est une
des enseignements qu'on a et qu'il a
aussi peut-être d'ailleurs peut-être que
le port du masque en général je prends
le temps en permanence cher monsieur
mais perdurera là aussi par rapport à la
prévention de certaines épidémies plus
saisonnière comme il le fait dans
d'autres dans d'autres pays en tout cas
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas sans
inconvénient un jeu je préférais de
beaucoup cher monsieur députés se
présente vous parlez sans masque je
m'imagine d'ailleurs que tous ici elle
demain à disposition d'esprit mais j'ai
quand même la faiblesse de penser que si
vous le portez c'est pas tant pour
mettre agréable et pas tant parce que
j'ai édicter des décrets comme je disais
tout à l'heure rendant son port
obligatoire mais c'est parce qu'aussi
vous pensez que ça peut être utile pour
votre propre protection et celle de non
seulement de vos collègues députés mais
de votre entourage
et ça c'est un point me semble-t-il
encore une fois essentiel je ne cherche
qu'à une chose se députés voulaient
employée la formule équilibrer les
choses
c'est un équilibre comment dire qu'il
n'est pas facile à atteindre
ça je vous le concède tout fait
volontiers avec ne doutait pas que ce
soit mon objectif si je prend des
mesures difficiles
je le répète c'est que je pense qu'elles
sont dans l'intérêt des françaises et
des français dans l'intérêt de la lutte
contre cette épidémie
les sociétés occidentales très
développés comme les nôtres ne sont pas
habitués à ça extrêmement perturbée elle
pense vous qui êtes médecin que la
science est devenue toute puissante
qu'elle a réglé ce type de phénomène
dans notre inconscient collectif on
aurait plutôt tendance à renvoyer
moyenne
même si après tout 1920 et la crise
espagnole c'est pas si vieux que ça mais
on a fait de tels progrès depuis lors et
notamment des progrès scientifiques que
on peut considérer où on s'est habitués
à considérer est ce que je peux
comprendre lui reste que ce type de
phénomène avait disparu sinon de la
surface du globe en tout cas de la
surface des sociétés dites développées
bon et bien voilà je ne fais pas de
commentaires je constate avec vous que
telle n'est pas la réalité que du coup
tant les états que les systèmes
sanitaires en sont perturbés que les
opinions publiques en sommes
profondément affectés mais je le répète
c'est notre devoir collectif adam la
députée collectif et chacun a sa place
et chacun dans ses responsabilités
croyez bien que je mesure l'importance
des miels et que je ne m'y soustrait pas
mais c'est collectivement encore une
fois que nous relèverons ce défi grave
et inédit parce que j'ai quand même je
vous le dit monsieur le président sans
partage et à la conviction que en
sortira de cette affaire je ne suis pas
capable de vous dire quand j'aimerais
tant pouvoir que nous allons nous
préparer à tout ça le mieux possible
nous apprenons chaque jour j'apprends
chaque jour dans la gestion de cette
crise il faut le faire avec humilité
avec détermination avec avec conviction
avec écoute écoute mais je pense qu'il
n'y a pas d'autre voie que celle à la
fois de la fermeté dans un certain
nombre de principes et de la
bienveillance vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens parce que j'ai parfaitement
conscience qu'ils subissent ici comme
ailleurs une épreuve vraiment redoutable
merci je passe la parole à monsieur d'or
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre deux trois choses
rapide
je soutiens bien entendu les
propositions de damien abad sur le
principe de tester tracé est isolé car
c'est véritablement connaître la carte
épidémiologique de notre pays donc plus
on testera et plus on trouvera une
certaine carte qui pourra nous
renseigner sur l'avenir d'ailleurs des
pays l'ont fait vous l'avez rappelé
l'autriche la finlande et liverpool il
ya peu de temps
comment envisagez vous monsieur le
premier ministre
le déconfinement avec une note d'espoir
il faut qu'on ait ce soit quand même une
note d'espoir dans nos débats
en parlant de fin novembre début
décembre puisque j'ai cru comprendre
en l'espace de quelques jours qu'il y
avait une décroissance de près de 30% de
consultation chez tous les généralistes
de france 30% de moins de consultations
en l'espace de quelques jours
donc c'est quand même un signe très
positif je voudrais également vous
rappelez un petit peu vous avez évoqué
la cellule interministérielle de crise
monsieur le premier ministre vous venez
vous en 2006 je sais où vous étiez côté
de ségur il y a eu un décret qui était
signé pour un pilotage entre le délégué
interministérielle de la lutte contre la
grippe aviaire dilga associée au
secrétaire général de la défense
nationale ce binôme à gérer entièrement
les crises de l'époque et en 2007 il y a
eu la création de l'eprus également sous
votre séjour à ségur en 2009 lieu le
plan pandémie
tout cela était bien armé le pays était
armé
comment en sommes-nous arrivés là alors
que l'on à deux rapports vous n'êtes
plus vous n'étiez pas au mieux aux
responsabilités selon l'un deux rapports
l'un de la fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers et l'autre du que du
général ou généraliserait qui est un rat
peau de rapport qui met en cause brut
dont certaines cause la gestion
de la crise dès le démarrage dans les
premiers mois
voilà merci car vous pouvez avoir un
avis sur ces rapports merci beaucoup
madame perron merci monsieur le
président monsieur premier ministre à
propos du déconfit l'an passé et celui
auquel vous réfléchissez après cette
nouvelle vague
pouvez vous nous expliquer les
indicateurs et les critères qui ont
guidé à ce moment-là vous propositions
pour élaborer le plan du déconfinement
avec le recul
en quoi les problématiques seront elles
différentes plusieurs mois après
comment envisagez vous les prochains
mois sans simplement comment les
ressentez vous à l'heure où on se parle
faut-il préparer la population à des
épisodes successifs de mise en sommeil
de l'activité sociale jusqu'à ce que le
virus est été apprivoisés d'une manière
ou d'une autre
merci monsieur premier ministre merci
beaucoup monsieur gautier merci
président monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez signé le ségur de la santé
comme vous l'avez rappelé je voudrais
donc vous interroger sur une des
conséquences du ségur
le décret du 19 septembre 2020 et
notamment sur les oubliés de ceux de ce
décret qui prévoit un complètement de
traitement indiciaire pour les agents
des établissements publics de santé à
l'hôpital et en ehpad
ceci étant c'est certains soignants sont
sont exclus vous avez déclaré aussi
vouloir soutenir la santé mentale
c'est le cas des agents en psychiatrie
de maisons d'accueil spécialisées ou de
foyer d'accueil médicalisé
dieu sait s'il y a eu pourtant des
clusters par exemple dans des maisons
d'accueil spécialisées avec des
des agents touché des résidents
contaminé également or ces agents des
masses et des femmes qui dépendent du
centre hospitalier de psychiatrie sont
exclus de cette revalorisation de la
même façon les personnels des siad des
services de soins infirmiers à domicile
que c'est là aussi qu'on essaye de
privilégier l'accompagnement de nos
personnes âgées à domicile le plus
longtemps possible
ça fait un peu près de quarante mille
personnes au niveau national qui sont
qui sont exclus avec des conséquences
très net c'est à peu près 2000 euros net
par an de différence d'où le sentiment
d'une certaine injustice de soignants à
deux vitesses et une perte
d'attractivité pour ces métiers avec
parfois des demandes de mutation des
fuites de personnel et et des jeunes qui
ne choisissent plus ces filières alors
qu'on a déjà des taux d'encadrement qui
sont insuffisants qu'on a des postes
vacants et des difficultés de
recrutement
alors monsieur le premier ministre c'est
jason ses agents
vous écoute vous entends fondre et vous
attendent surtout à la proche de noël et
j'aimerais profiter de cette phase
d'auditions au fait monsieur le premier
ministre
comment voyez-vous noël ou bien enfin
mettre une barde madame corneloup en
visio je crois c'est bon je meubles
c'est comme quand tu as technique un
problème c'est comment au journal
télévisé je vais demander à monsieur
pons peut-être de poser sa question en
attendant monsieur pons oui merci
monsieur le président c'est vrai qu'à
arriver à la fin de ce long débat s'est
il faut savoir se répéter et c'est
important
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
dit que de travailler avec humilité
écoute et combattre la maladie
je crois que c'est les qualités d'un
très bon médecin peut-être une carrière
que vous auriez pu envisager
vous savez que c'est un très beau métier
surtout actuellement je crois que
répéter des choses c'est important dans
la mesure où on voit les manifestations
je parlerai pas de moto au mans où
certaines réflexions les deux choses
dont on est sûr de ce virus comme je dis
souvent c'est son nom est le seul
traitement pour l'instant que nous ayons
c'est le confinement
il n'ya pas d'autre traitement ce qui
veut dire que tout déplacement entraîne
la mobilité de ce virus
d'où l'importance du confinement que
vous avez donc décrété et bien sûr il
serait facile d'ouvrir le robinet mais
quelle avec quel danger
quel danger puisque nous sommes non pas
au milieu non pas de la confiance tout
en haut de la courbe donc extrêmement
fragile et je pense vous pouvez le
confirmer que ouvrir le robinet quel
qu'il soit pourrait entraîner de graves
de graves conséquences
et ceci dit c'est cette maladie qui est
encore reconnue bien sûr on va avoir une
bientôt le vaccin mais ce vaccin c'est
pas un traitement c'est une prophylaxie
et encore s'il est accepté par par tout
le monde
j'espère qu'il sera accepté pour
l'instant on parle de 50 % on voit
actuellement une approche plus
importante vis-à-vis du vaccin contre la
grippe ce qui est important l'année
dernière je vaccine et très peu et là il
ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de monde
qui est demande de ce vaccin est la
dernière chose que faire de ces gens qui
font de la résistance
voire même ceux qui veulent payer payer
des pl et les amendes les dires les
écrivains qui veulent payer des amendes
des libraires les mères qui veulent
payer des amendes pour leurs commerçants
je pense que quelque part c'est quand
même assez irresponsable
il vous remercie et pour terminer madame
corneloup merci beaucoup monsieur le
président entendez vous cette fois-ci
vous entend parfaitement bien non vous
voir plus c'est à dire très bien je vous
en parlais tout à l'heure mais
apparemment vous ne m'entendez pas là
monsieur ministre le virus et
contrairement au printemps dernier
répartis de manière égale sur le
territoire la flambée des infections
qu'ovide met sous pression notre système
hospitalier
nous savons qu aujourd'hui 95% de nos
capacités sont atteintes
ce qui concerne les lits de réanimation
la seule façon d'admettre les nouveaux
cas c'est effectivement de faire appel à
la déprogrammation et nous savons
qu'aujourd'hui déjà un certain nombre
d'actes ont été déprogrammés afin de
libérer des places disponibles or nous
avons la problématique de mars dernier
où des patients ont été déprogrammés et
à ce jour ceux-ci n'ont pas encore été
reprogrammée avec le risque d'une vague
de patients non qu'ovide lié à la
présence d'hivernal ne pensez vous pas
que le nombre de lits de réanimation est
une vraie problématique
je vous ai entendu dire qu'il était très
difficile d'augmenter le nombre de lits
de réanimation parce que cela supposait
du personnel qualifié mais d'autres pays
nous l'avons vu l'italie a réussi à si
rapidement faire monter en compétences
et personnel pour qu'ils viennent en
renfort des équipes de réanimation
donc je voulais vous entendre par
rapport à cela comment également
comptez-vous sanctuariser la prise en
charge des pathologies les plus graves
et puis j'aurais rebondir sur deux
éléments qui ont appelé mes collègues
notamment concernant la santé psychique
nous avons aujourd'hui un climat qui est
très anxiogène avec une stratégie de la
peur qui est véhiculé et
notion de culpabilité qui petit à petit
s'installe celle-ci et grave à la fois
pour les enfants et pour les adultes
également
avez vous envisagé un accompagnement et
sous quelle forme
aujourd'hui et demain pour toutes ces
personnes qui ne vont pas bien et puis
ma dernière interrogation comporte
également la revalorisation des salaires
dans le cadre du ségur de la santé avait
effectivement ces personnels oublié je
pense effectivement aux femmes je pense
également au ciad ces personnels ont
l'impression alors qu'elles ont été
énormément mise à contribution de ne pas
avoir été considérés et ça génère chez
de beaucoup de découragement je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup mais écoutez monsieur
communistre je vous laisse répondre à
cette dernière question
alors y at il des motifs d'espérer
ce député bon alors écoutez je viens
d'avoir les chiffres de ce soir voit que
le le taux d'incidence nationale
continue de diminuer à vous l'avez vu il
était hier à 258 il ya 248 c'est pas
voilà je rappelle qu'il est monté
jusqu'à 480 tous les députés ici il y à
une baisse des lits occupés en animation
- 65 ce qui ici mes données sont exactes
porte 1 4854 le nombre de lits
actuellement occupés dans les services
de réanimation
j'allais dire il faut continuer sur tout
ça ça prouve que nos efforts collectifs
portent leurs fruits mais monsieur le
député je suis d'accord il est encore
trop tôt pour ouvrir le robinet cette
expression est de vous je sais pas si je
dois la la préférée a desserré la bride
puisque visiblement ça peut être l'objet
d'interprétations fallacieuses
mais voilà du parce que patiemment mais
sûrement il faut que nous continuons
dans cette direction je le dis parce que
je me suis encore sûrement mal expliqué
à l'ats la dernière intervenante les
italiens ils ont fait comme nous c'est à
dire on a cinq mille lits de réanimation
avec les professionnels adaptés
on peut les doubles et ne nie pas avoué
koné 1 4854 donc sauf 4854 ces cocos
vide que kovy ballet à 10000 d'accord 1
comme je les dis répartissant les
personnels existants etc faisant appel
aux étudiants en médecine à la réserve
etc et c'est ce qu'on fait au maximum le
là ce qui fait un peu la différence par
rapport à d'autres états c'est que le
nombre de lits de départ c'est à dire et
à ce qui existait avec les personnes
correspondant au moment où la crise est
survenue c'est à dire grosso modo en
janvier dernier était peut-être un peu
inférieurs à ceux d'autres pays
mais ça c'est une constatation
rétrospective mais en tout cas il n'est
pas possible maladie n'est pas possible
de laisser à penser qu'on peut recruter
former en six mois des médecins
anesthésistes réanimateurs je vous
invite comme moi aller faire le tour des
établissements de santé des services
réanimation
ils vous expliqueront cela de façon
beaucoup plus convaincante visiblement
que je ne parviens à le faire mais voilà
enfin en tout cas pour l'instant
puisqu'on parlait de préparation nous
nous étions préparés avec eux à aller
jusqu'à dix mille sept cents ans né à
4854 ce qui va du coup je réponds à vos
questions parfaitement légitime
permettre de moins des programmes et et
de plus continuer à admettre
animation des patients qui ne souffre
pas de l'aco vide et c'est bien
l'objectif tout à fait raison de le
rappeler
bon alors j'ai eu des questions sur le
ségur de la santé je voudrais dire comme
c'est vrai vous avez je comprends que
vous parliez des oubliés mais enfin
c'est quand même un effort historique
député jean-pierre door voulait bien
rappeler le passé non mais tu as par les
gens qui avaient parlé de l'époque
antérieure
vous avez ici même voté un ondam qui est
la traduction de ce ségur en tout cas de
la tranche évidemment de 2021
depuis que cet outil existe nous n'avons
jamais eu autant de moyens affectés à
l'hôpital et à ses personnels
on peut je comprends votre question
c'est habituel insisté sur ce qui manque
ce qui ne va pas ouvrir ma faim je ne
souhaiterais quand même pas qu'on oublie
qu'on fasse oublier à nos concitoyens
l'effort absolument significatif qui est
sans doute à attrape âge qui était qui
est sans doute tout à fait justifiée
mérité enfin qui existe qui existe alors
il ya deux sujets a été semble-t-il
d'abord y aller les le secteur de l'aide
à domicile pour faire simple monsieur le
député ou là dans la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale en cours d'examen
nous vous proposons des mesures de
revalorisation des personnels de l'aide
à domicile
et puis il ya le secteur médico social
or sanitaire vous avez évoqué plusieurs
sujets j ajouterai aussi les personnels
qui travaillent
vous ne les avez pas cité mais je pense
qu'il embrassait votre pensée votre
propos dans des établissements aux sites
qui accueillent des enfants et des
adultes handicapés
c'est le même voilà on est d'accord donc
je vous informe que hier matin à la
faveur du conseil interministériel
consacré aux handicaps que j'ai présidé
conseil que pour la première fois j'ai
ouvert aux associations représentatives
du secteur
j'ai annoncé que nous allions nous
emparé du sujet que j'ai mandaté une
personnalité qualifiée en l'espèce
monsieur michel lafourcade ancien
directeur général de la rs de nouvelles
aquitaine pour faire des propositions
dégager des priorités parce qu'on ne
pourra pas tout régler d'un seul coup je
préfère le dire en responsabilité à la
représentation nationale mais sachez qu
effectivement nous avons parfaitement
conscience du problème monsieur le
député que vous soulevez et
le nous y apporterons et d'ailleurs ça
viendra forcément devant vous un
s'agissant de mesures ayant une
incidence financière nous essaierons d'y
apporter les réponses les plus les plus
adaptées le député jean perdre
précisément posé une question sur sur
l'organisation sur l'organisation
bon il a fait allusion au rapport du
général lizurey ce que j'ai d'ailleurs à
votre demande je lui pardonne moi je me
suis un peu plus si c'est le président
rapporteur général comme unité donc vous
l'avez vu vous vous aurez d'ailleurs
sans doute observer ou noter les
appréciations qui porte lui même sur la
mission sur le décompte finement ce
rapporteur général
le rapport lizurey fait toute une série
de préconisations vingt-et-une très
précisément et je peux vous dire que
d'ores et déjà 15 d'entre elles ont été
mises en oeuvre pour les mesures les
plus structurelles qui vont notamment
dans le sens de la question posée par le
député compte tenu de
notamment aux anneaux me notamment aussi
ce qui concerne l'organisation
territoriale de la gestion de la crise
j'ai été conduit puisque c'était la
préconisation de monsieur lizurey de
saisir l'inspection générale de
l'administration et l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales
je les ai saisi dès le 18 août je le dis
elles viennent il y a huit jours de nous
rendre leurs rapports avec les séries de
deux préconisations organisationnel que
je tiens bien entendu ceux présents
monsieur le rapporteur général à
disposition de la de la commission
donkey typo pointe un certain nombre
comme l'a fait monsieur lizurey de
pistes d'amélioration pardonnez moi de
vous répéter que s'agissant des
préconisations beaucoup plus
structurelle quel qu'en soit le bien
fondé je pense qu'il faudra que nous les
mettions en oeuvre qu'on ne peut pas les
mettre en oeuvre dans le feu de l'action
ce serait totalement irresponsable il
faut laisser le dispositif tel qu'il est
qui s'améliore et qui encore une fois
c'est ce que reconnaît aussi défection
général n'est pas ce qu'on va dire a
aussi des aspects extrêmement positif je
rappelle que nous avions sur la base des
recommandations du général les jurés
qu'ils étaient des recommandations et la
fera pas mais il faisait sachez le des
recommandations fil de l'eau dans le
cadre de sa mission d'ailleurs si vous
lisez je crois que je lui ai transmis sa
lettre de mission c'est de michel elle
parle pas de rapport elle invite le
général juge lise huret qui je le dis
pour la banque nationale est elle le
précédent directeur général de la
gendarmerie nationale à faire au cabinet
du premier ministre que vient de mon
prédécesseur d des observations en
direct et c'est entre autres sur la base
de ces préconisations et sûr de celle
que j'avais moi même formulé dans le cas
de ma mission des codes finement que
nous avons réorganisé le dispositif de
crise et unifié autour du centre
interministériel de crise alors c'est
pas les mêmes sujets
que l'eprus est bien d'accord avec le
lien avec par contre le secrétariat
général de la défense et la sécurité
nationale qui a été évoqué par monsieur
d'ordre dans sa question en unifiant
donc le dispositif de pilotage et ce qui
était encore une fois recommandé entre
autres par le rapport du général du rpt
est question m'a été posée sur sur les
amendes et les attitudes
notamment de jeu passe de certains
maires qui ont pris des arrêtés parce
que c'est ça monsieur le député qui
laissait les commerces ouverts ou même
certains d'entre eux qui ont dit nous
paierons à lui est pas bon je me suis
déjà exprimé le ministre d'intérieur
également en vous disant que très
clairement et très calme en ce n'est pas
admissible députés un peu le pas être
d'accord avec avec tel ou tel aspect de
la politique ou des lois de la
république
enfin les voilà les lois de la
république doivent être appliquées et
respectées et d'ailleurs j'observe quand
même que ce mouvement n'a pas quand même
était extrêmement étendue je pense qu'il
ya pas eu davantage de 200 maires je
rappelle qu'il ya trente-six mille qui
ont pris ce type d'arrêté encore moins
qui ont indiqué qu' il se tenait à la
disposition des commerçants pour payer
les amendes
bon c'est pas ben c'est pas un bon
exemple dit c'est pas ce qu'il faut
faire et donc nous avons demandé au
préfet d'intervenir une certain nombre
de maires ont d'ailleurs sachez le
retirer à la suite de ces interventions
leurs arrêtés
d'autres préfets ont dû les déférer
devant les tribunaux et il ne vous a pas
échappé que fort logiquement les
tribunaux ont donné raison au préfet
mais disons que au delà des aspects
juridiques et de la nécessaire du
nécessaire respect de l'autorité de
l'état
derrière mon grand regret c'est qu'il y
a c'était un peu le sens de votre
question c'est est une insuffisante
compréhension de la gravité de la
situation sanitaire c'est surtout ça le
président a fait allusion à mon
déplacement à saint-etienne dans son
propos liminaire saint-etienne était ne
le sont plus mais était malheureusement
confronté il ya quelques semaines vous
le savez à
un pic épidémique parmi les plus élevés
de france
et bien sachez le les commerçants
spontanément appliquer les textes
le maire de saint-etienne n'a pas pris
d'arrêté peut-être pas tellement pour
être pour pouvoir se conformer aux je
l'espère aux décisions gouvernementales
mais surtout parce que voilà vous étiez
dans une ville où on voyait que il y
avait des personnes dans son entourage
enfin que la gravité de la situation
sanitaire n'est n'est pas le fruit de
d'un complot ou d'une quelconque
l'invention de l'appareil d'état et des
autorités gouvernementales
donc quand les gens voient ça c'est bon
il faut te il faut se protéger il faut
respecter ça allons-y faisant le tout de
suite pour pouvoir après essayer comme
l'a dit comme vous l'avez dit plus
d'entre vous une nouvelle étape avec
davantage d'espoir et on me demander
comment je tout le monde voyait noël
dont je répète ce que je vous ai dit
lors de main toute première réponse je
n'imagine pas qu'on saura le 1er
décembre comme on l'était avec les mêmes
règles applicables dans l'entrée du
deuxième confinement je pense que nous
en ferons une sortie progressive
progressive je ne suis pas encore un
état devant cette commission denquête de
dire exactement quelle sera comment dire
le curseur de cette progressivité ne
serait ce que parce que même si les
chiffres que je vous donne sont plutôt
encourageants je ne peux pas vous dire à
aucun d'entre vous et personne ne peut
le faire quel sera exactement autour du
1er décembre la situation
épidémiologique et la situation dans le
système hospitalier notamment dans les
lits de réanimation mais j'ai espoir
j'ai espoir jeu parce que voilà c'est
pas que j'ai envie de vous dire devant
vous parce que les mesures qu'on a
prises sont bonnes ça c'est à vous
d'apprécier mais ça veut dire que les
français gros globalement les
comprennent les applique
bon et donc ça doit nous permettre on a
déjà dit si on peut desserrer
effectivement les commerces de proximité
qui ne sont pas qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
fermées parce qu'il ne sommes pas et ne
vendent pas des des produits
alimentaires ou autres ce pourrait être
effectivement les premiers concernés on
l'a déjà dit le président de la
république a indiqué par exemple ce
matin
s'agissant des enfants il l'a dit aux
associations de fortis associant
sportive ne peuvent plus vous le savez
accueillir d'enfants sauf l'école et le
périscolaire crois qu'il serait assez
logique avec nous-mêmes que si nous si
nous ouvrons il faudra aussi pouvoir
permettre à ces à ses enfants de pouvoir
aller dans l'est dans les clubs sportifs
pour pratiquer des activités physiques
et sportives mais mais il y aura sans
doute d'autres secteurs où il sera
difficile dès le début décembre 2 et
donc nous devrons essayer de donner le
maximum de visibilité la même façon le
jeu je le dis même si c'est parfois un
peu compliqué entendre le président de
la république l'a dit on ne peut pas
imaginer que pendant les fêtes de noël
réveillant etc
on pourra laisser des grands
rassemblements et le virus circule et
pourquoi parce que ça voudrait dire coop
on devrait à nouveau serré un tour de
vis à nous d'y graver qu'est ce que vous
avez fait et c'est bon voilà et je sais
par avance que prendre des décisions
difficiles de cette nature va susciter
les critiques et des reproches des mêmes
sans doute que ce qui ici je ne les
prends pas comme le rapporteur général
me l'a dit tout à l'heure pour le 11
septembre m'expliquera vous auriez dû le
faire voilà l'a compris c'est important
voilà donc il va falloir trouver moi
j'aime bien la notion d' équilibre que
vous avez employé
le sel de la vie non cher nous
recherchons toutes et tous juste milieu
c'est ce que c'est ce que je m'emploie à
faire je répète je sais que tout ça est
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement
difficile mais je voudrais m'inscrire
effectivement dans une perspective qui
irait au moins jusqu'à l'été prochain va
dire ça comme ça c'est encore une fois
les vaccins produisent tous leurs effets
que ya pas de difficulté qu'on fait et c
est qu on est débarrassé de cette
affaire gm dont le plus heureux du monde
ce sera moi même enfin avec vous aussi
sans doute mais mon devoir est de
préparer une situation va dire un peu
stabilisé pour éviter effectivement ce
set
c'est à coups qui sont encore plus
difficiles à supporter par par nos
concitoyens
je crois que j'ai à peu près pondu à
tous merci beaucoup monsieur le premier
ministre pour cette audition
merci beaucoup je souhaite mais chaque
collègue monsieur le ministre
une bonne soirée